in case you missed last night's
presidential debate between president
trump and
joe biden i will sum it up for you in
seven seconds
that was it that was the debate except
instead of seven seconds
it was 90 minutes of that the debate was
mostly a draw
and a missed opportunity and president
trump spent most of the time debating
the
moderator chris wallace but there was a
point
president trump did get a very important
message
out to people and everyone seems to have
missed it but it was a very important
message it was actually worth
that 90 minutes of yammering and
screaming
and heckling which we will get into i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from top 10
guy one
who says for democrats stopping them
from
cheating equals voter suppression lol
yes that's true it is voters because the
democrats
don't want you to disenfranchise all of
those dead voters in ohio
all of those uh family pets that have
been dead for 20 years
all of those illegal aliens foreign
nationals they don't want you to
to disenfranchise those people that
would be suppression of votes
that should should not be cast in the
first place
if you watched the debate last night you
probably left disappointed regardless of
what side you were on
probably if you were to sum up the
debate
you'd say that trump won it he got he
got more
zingers in he seemed more lively and yet
probably biden supporters are happier
this morning than than trump supporters
because biden is allegedly ahead in the
polls and mias biden didn't completely
collapse on the stage
and because the moderator chris wallace
constantly ran interference for
joe biden bailed him out of a lot of
tight spots and was
downright rude to president trump
president trump
got some zingers in he did he did
hit some points that were substantive
and i think you'd be able to break out
and put in some campaign commercials
the first one was framing
this the strongest issue for democrats
health care that's the one they always
come back to even when health care
has absolutely nothing to do with the
election or the the issues at hand
so what president trump did was flip it
and show
how a joe biden presidency would destroy
american health care
what i proposed is that uh we expand
obamacare
and we increase it we do not wipe any
and
one of the big debates we had with 23 of
my colleagues trying to win the
nomination that i won
we're saying that biden wanted to allow
people to have private insurance still
they can they do they will under my
proposal not what you've said
and it's not what the party is saying
that is simply the party doesn't say
your party wants to go socialist
party is socialist right now i am and
they're going to dominate you joe you
know that
i am the democratic party right now your
party wants socialist medicine and
socialist health care and they're going
to dominate you joe you know that this
was a very smart framing here
which is not to say joe biden is a
radical he's a far leftist he's a
socialist
because nobody believes that joe biden's
been in office since before karl marx
was born
you know joe biden's been around a long
time he's positioned himself at various
times as a moderate
and at other times he's moved further to
the left
so that wouldn't be persuasive but what
we do know what is undeniable
is that joe biden is weak he's a weak
front-runner he's a weak leader of his
party he's a weak presidential nominee
and he will be swayed and dominated by
other members of the party
actually when that uh that communist
woman angela davis
uh this this awful far left uh woman
who is very influential in the
democratic party when she endorsed joe
biden
she said i'm endorsing joe biden not
because i think he's a radical but
because i think that we can
bully him into doing what we want same
thing is true
of bob avakian the head of the
revolutionary communist party in america
he said yeah i'm going to endorse joe
biden because we're going to be able to
bully him so that was the point
trump picked up on that i think is
persuasive because people who still
have horrible memories of obamacare
losing their doctor premiums going up
they're going to remember oh wait a
second
joe biden's now promising more socialist
health care joe biden was in part
responsible for
for the obamacare mess i don't think i
want any part of that that was a good
singer
trump also got in one line they clearly
had written it out and rehearsed it
about joe biden's pie in the sky
promises and the likelihood that they're
actually going to come true
he says he's smart because he can take
advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're going to
eliminate those taxes
and make sure that we invest in the
people who in fact
need the help people out there need help
but why didn't you do it over time in
the last 25 years
because you weren't present because you
weren't president screwing things up
you were a senator you're the worst
president america has ever had
let me just tell you joe i've done more
in in 47 months
i've done more than you've done in 47
years joe
oh that's a good line that is some of
these scripted lines are not that good
and they kind of go over as groaners
which joe biden had one of those later
in the debate he said you
you say it's the heart of the deal you
do the art of the steel please clap
please it was like so lame but that's a
good line i've done more in 47 months
than you've done in 47 years
because you have to look at the timeline
of joe biden you say okay a guy gets
elected to the senate in 1973
senate senate senate senate senate and
senate senate said
senate vice president vice president
vice president vice president
vice president and he's out he's running
for office but now he's going to change
everything
now he just needed 46 years head start
and now starting in this 47th year now
he's going to change
everything trump made another good point
when when biden was hitting him on the
tax code
he said joe you wrote the tax bill
you're the one who gave me these tax
advantages so that was a good zinger i
think you can break that out you're
gonna see some t-shirts of
i've done more in 47 months than you've
done in 47 years and then
i thought the best hit it was the
closest thing that trump got to a clean
hit of the night it wasn't a major hit
but it's it could be somewhat useful is
joe biden was talking about how cops
like him so much
and trump said name one name one
law enforcement agency that supports you
he has no law enforcement that's not
true almost that's not
look who do you have name one group that
supports you name one group that came
out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time we don't
have time to do anything
all right one law enforcement group
that came back gentlemen i think i'm
going to i'm going to take back the
moderators
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests
in many cities that have turned violent
gentlemen gentlemen i have to interject
here because the president
just landed a brutal blow on joe biden
so we cannot
uh mr biden don't answer that i'll don't
i'll step in you obviously can't step in
but i'll step in
i'm chris wallace the moderator
yeah the mod is he's just trying to
moderate all of the attacks he's trying
to temper all of the attacks
that trump landed on joe biden it was
uh there were a few moments that were
pretty brutal where
where i felt joe was really threatened
and by the way there are a lot of
threats out there for all of us which is
why you need to get life insurance
that's why you need to check out select
quote
select quote comparison shops highly
rated companies including prudential
banner life mutual of omaha others
to find you the company with the best
rates so just to give you an example of
this
select quote could find a 35 year old
man a half million dollar policy
for less than 19 a month i got to take
note of that i got to remember that
that's a very good deal
cup of coffee a day costs more than that
costs a lot more than that actually
select quotes breakthrough technology
allows them to quickly match you with
the best insurance company
to find your best policy plus the quotes
are free i really love select quote you
know i'm a little bit of a luddite i'm
not huge into technology
but i love using technology when it can
be extremely helpful and simple and just
common sense
select quote is so clear for that you
just go there and they just they do all
the shopping for you they just give you
those quotes
select quote saves you time and money
get your free quote at selectquote.com
today that is selectquote.com for your
free quote
don't put off protecting your family
another day selectquote.com
get full details on the example policy
select quote.com
commercials your premium could vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors
not available in all states so trump
landed some blows
okay joe biden also
landed some i wouldn't say he landed
blows he he just landed
insults they were both insulting one
another i felt trump got cleaner hits in
against
joe biden joe biden for all the talk we
hear of civility
and the soul of america and how donald
trump is taking down the tone of our
public discourse
joe biden was much nastier and more
childish than donald trump
much it wasn't even close joe biden said
things that were shameful downright
shameful
to say to the president of the united
states called him a clown yelled at him
to shut up
and call them that classic the classic
insult that means it means any type of
bad person called him a racist you
agreed
with bernie sanders on a plan
absolutely you have any idea
socialized medicine mr president tell
you what vote now
make sure you in fact let people know
we're senators
i'm not going to answer the question
because you answered that because the
question is
the question is radical left will you
shut up listen who is on your list joe
this is on your right gentlemen i think
this is
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment that
was really a
productive segment wasn't it
keep yapping man the people understand
yeah 47 years you've done nothing they
understand
all right they were teaching people that
our country is a horrible place it's a
racist place
and they were teaching people to hate
our country and i'm not going to allow
that to happen
vice president biden nobody's doing that
he's just
he's racist here's the deal i i know a
lot more about it
so unpresidential i'm not going to
defend trump's badgering the whole night
though i actually
i do have a point on trump's badgering
generally i felt it was ineffective
because he did it too much
but generally we will get to that
who was more or less presidential here
trump was much more presidential and i
get it that the badgering is
sort of tedious i get it it is
unacceptable childish stupid
disrespectful rude wrong
to tell the president of the united
states to shut up
i find the phrase shut up to be one of
the
rudest phrases you can utter you have to
do it very selectively
one time when when ronald reagan was
being shouted down by a whole horde
of these awful anti-american hippies he
he famously told me goes oh shut up you
know he's like sort of half joking and
it
was
that was an effective use of that term
when you use that term
just in normal conversation it's
incredibly rude you could
you could instead use a much more vile
vulgar sort of word
and it would be less rude than that say
call him a clown the president of united
states a clown
and then to say he's a racist
i i just don't that phrase i
maybe at some point it had some meaning
it certainly doesn't anymore
george orwell in politics in the english
language said that the term fascist now
has no meaning it just means
some something that is not desirable
something that i don't like well
the same is true of racist there's no it
doesn't matter there's no
it even if somebody had racial bigotry
racial prejudices
the term doesn't matter the term even if
you walked up to david duke you walked
up to the head of the ku klux klan you
said you're a racist
the phrase itself has been deprived of
meaning because of people like joe biden
because he says you're ah i can't oh
well man i lost my train of thought and
i can't
gosh trump's off-footing me with the
badger you're a racist
you're a racist he was pathetic it's
totally pathetic
then at certain moments joe biden
actually
beyond the petty insults actually seemed
to undermine his own arguments
so when they were sniping each other
over the lockdowns
joe biden seemed to come out against the
lockdowns
i'll tell you joe you could never have
done the job that we did you don't have
it in your blood you could have never
done that yet
i know how to do the job i know how to
get the job well you didn't do very well
in swine flu
h1n1 you were a disaster your own
there's no we didn't shut down the
economy this is his economy that's being
he's shut down
what first of all
h1 i mean this is why the attack on h1n1
i see why trump launched it but
because the two diseases are so
incomparable
and then he tried to make that point
later right he said it was much less
lethal but because they're so kind he
left himself open to that that counter
attack
but i didn't expect joe's counter attack
to say well we didn't shut down the
economy for h1n1
joe you're it's you guys who are trying
to shut down the economy now trump wants
to open the economy
and just five seconds ago you were
demagoguing the issue and saying trump's
killing people because he won't shut
down the economy
so what is it do the democrats want to
shut down the economy
or do they want to open up the economy
right now it's only the democratic
governors
practically who are trying to keep it
shut down right gavin newsom
uh the mayor eric our city in los
angeles andrew cuomo governor of new
york
bill de blasio mayor in new york it's
all the democrats who want to shut it
down
so but joe that this is the trouble with
being a cynical
empty suit politician he doesn't have
any beliefs it's not just that he's
lying it's that he has no regard for the
truth so he says okay now it's
now it's good to hit him for the
lockdowns and it doesn't even occur to
him like wait a second but we were the
ones pushing the lockdowns
on him or arguing i just undercut our
argument that doesn't matter and i think
for a lot of his
partisans it probably won't matter much
either and then the most ridiculous
thing biden said all night
beyond the petty insults which you kind
of expect
he was he was asked to condemn antifa
and he held the party line he said
antifa doesn't exist
somebody's got to do something about
antifa and the left because this is not
a right-wing problem
this is a left-hand direction this is a
left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization you've got it not
militia
that's what his tonight fbi his fbi
director said well then
no no no we're not we're done sir and he
we're we're done we're done mr trump you
can't please don't respond to that
because that statement that joe made was
so obviously indefensible
that please please don't respond we got
to move on new segment new site we got
that's the sacred sacred news segment
antifa's an idea not an organization
antifa may be an idea but it's an idea
that has gotten into people's heads and
those people wear uniforms and they wave
a flag and they march
and organize together that is an
organization
you could say this you could say look
look fascism
is an idea it's not an organization
which is true
but in mussolini's italy that idea was
embodied by people who wore black shirts
and committed violence in the streets
nazism is an idea it's not an
organization sure it is an idea
it was embodied by people who wore brown
shirts and worked for adolf hitler in
germany
well communism is an idea it's not an
organization sure but it manifests
in organizations and antifa has a real
organization right now
coincidentally members of antifa are
alternately anarchists and
communists and all sorts of miscreants
and narrative wells and very bad
people we know that they i can see the
videos of them waving their flag
that is the definition of an
organization but they can't cop to it
and so trump's getting a lot of
uh flack right now because they they
pulled out the typical court they say
trump do you condem white supremacists
he goes sure
yeah okay yes of course i defend white
supremacists or do i
pardon me i condemn white supremacists
uh
who do you want me to condemn who do you
want me to condemn
and they say the proud boys okay yeah
proud boys go away okay yeah
do we do it but joe you're defending
antifa and joe says there's no such
thing as antifa
now you've heard in some of these clips
chris wallace chris wallace is the key
he just keeps jumping
in and in and in okay
and the
it became a one versus two debate which
made the whole thing
much more frustrating to watch
okay but i think trump had to know that
going in he had to realize
that there there were going to be
threats that were not totally fair
that he you know coming out of the
shadows coming out of the corner
is chris wallace and he might have been
able to predict those attacks a little
bit better
if he'd had a ring you know ring makes
you feel safe
wherever you are in your home or
actually out of your home even too
thousand reasons why protecting your
home should matter
to you ring has security products for
every corner
inside out you can go do it outside with
the floodlight you can do it
obviously on the outside with the
doorbell all over the place
and with ringing keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone
sweet little alisa my beloved wife she's
a good shot okay
but when i travel when i'm on the road
even when i'm at the office
gives me peace of time mind rather to
know that there is
ring ring that i can rely on
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need
to protect it and this is my little
secret i give this out to my friends as
a housewarming gift
in part because i love my friends i want
to protect them
but in part because it is inexpensive
and it seems
so incredibly super cool that i get a
lot of credit and i don't have to shell
out a lot of money
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com knowles
you get rings video doorbell 3 and shine
pro the perfect way to start your ring
experience
plus two day free shipping go to
ring.com knowles
ring.com slash knowles
there was the secret threat that came
into the debate though i'm sure trump
predicted it and that was chris wallace
chris wallace
i believe is a democrat but he's on fox
news and fox news is supposed to be the
sort of conservative news channel
and we are only getting one debate one
of these debates will be moderated by us
someone who even has an association
really with conservatives
and it was this unfair this
unfair so what are the other ones going
to be like
what when you've got actual not just
regular old left-wingers but
left-wingers at totally 100
left-wing networks not just sort of
middle-of-the-road networks
what's that two on one going to look
like trump called him out at one point
trump said okay chris i didn't realize i
wasn't billed
to be debating you tonight but that's
fine no big deal my individual mandate
was the most unpopular
aspect of obamacare
and i would like you to let me ask my
question and then you can answer
you in the course of these four years
have never come up with a comprehensive
plan
to replace obamacare and
just this last thursday you signed a
largely symbolic executive order to
protect people
with pre-existing conditions five days
before this debate
so my question sir is what is the trump
health care plan
well first of all i guess i'm debating
you not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised let me just tell you something
that
there's nothing symbolic i'm cutting
drug prices i'm going with favored
nations which no president has a courage
to do because you're going against big
pharma
drug prices will be coming down 80 or 90
percent
you could have done it during your 47
year period in government but you didn't
do it
and wallace he goes on that line
whenever you call out the moderator the
moderator does have to take a little bit
of a step back but not for very long and
it was pretty pathetic even
chris wallace's fox news colleagues some
of them privately
but but many of them even publicly
said this was not a great performance
you can see they were posting it all on
on twitter last night it was too much
that is always at risk i remember i did
a debate with
with a fox news democrat at politicon
this was i guess a year ago and almost
exactly a year ago over in nashville
and the the moderator was clay aiken and
the fox news democrat was
uh chris hahn the bald guy chris han
called me skinny boy
and uh so i i prepared the debate
against chris hahn
but at the very last minute i realized
wait a second
there's another guy here who's the
technically the moderator but
i i know that clay can ran for office as
a democrat
i know that clay aiken probably has
political views
and i know how these debates tend to go
against conservatives so i said you know
last minute
i'm just going to do a little little
research on on clay aiken just to make
sure i go so i go into the debate
chris han and i basically did not debate
that was chris hahn was just like kind
of a wallflower though i mean we got a
few barbs in or whatever
the actual debate was against the
moderator clay aiken
and that's what happened last night joe
biden did did not
come with his best or maybe he did come
with his best but his best aim very much
these days and frankly it wasn't even
that much during the height of his
career in the 80s and 90s
trump had to debate chris wallace
so it does raise questions about the
ground rules for the debate and for the
strategy the first thing i'll say
about about how this came out which i
think was a draw
i don't think it moved the needle one
little bit one way or the other
incumbents lose the first debate that
happens all the time you remember it
with barack obama he got crushed in the
first debate by mitt romney
in 2012. and mitt romney right it's not
exactly the fiercest debater out there
he ran roughshod over barack obama
ronald reagan
very famously got crushed in the first
debate to walter mondale in 1984.
ronald reagan this is a there was plenty
of reporting on this
according to uh to uh lou cannon who's
written about this
said as soon as reagan left the stage he
confessed he confessed to his adviser
stu spencer
that he had flopped you had uh
mondale walking off of the stage saying
to an aide
this guy is gone meaning he mentally
wasn't all there kind of the thing we
would say about joe biden
two days after the debate the rnc
chairman paul
laxalt held a press conference admitting
that reagan had done a bad job
and said no but it wasn't because his
brain has turned to mush
it's because the briefing process didn't
work very well you know the preparation
process
didn't work any well and uh he he just
got clobbered and then he came back
and crushed mondale in the later debate
same thing with obama obama came back
with the help of the
moderator quote unquote candy crowley
and crushed romney in the remainder of
the debates
so i'm not too worried if you have a
little bit of an historical view you say
this isn't going to change anything the
trouble with last night's debate is it
was exhausting
there was that i was watching it there
with ben jeremy and drew
we just said like oh gosh guys i got i
don't have enough hours in my
life to sit through this it's not it's
there's nothing productive about this
it's so exhausting and that's true
that's true and
we had a little bit of a disagreement
because we all thought that trump
interrupted too much
but i think ben was harsher on it than i
was
and ben kept bringing up this point this
is this is exhausting and this isn't
good and it's going to turn away voters
but the reason i disagree with that a
little bit is
trump has to be exhausting
he has to be if he wants to do anything
that matters as a conservative now you
don't need to be exhausting if you want
to just go along and get along with the
liberal establishment
because then you'll be treated
relatively well you know they'll still
probably beat you but maybe they'll let
you get
in as long as you play the game as long
as you as a conservative
play your role as the court jester in
the kingdom of liberalism
they'll more or less let you get along
but if you actually threaten things in
the way that trump has done
if you threaten their global trade
regime if you threaten their open
borders regime
if you threaten the loss of national
sovereignty to international and
transnational organizations as trump has
done
unlike any of his predecessors frankly
even including ronald reagan
if you do that they are all going to
come at you
all of the time hollywood the mainstream
media obviously the democratic
politicians the bureaucracy that tried
to have a coup d'etat and overthrow the
2016 election and kick him out of office
higher education lower education the
technology companies now which are
threatening to censor conservatives on
election night
all of these things are coming and that
they're already censoring conservatives
they're already censoring even the
president of the united states
saying that he's posting misinformation
when certainly that is not the case
all of these things are going to come
after you if you want to break through
that at
all you have to badger it's the same
disagreement about the tweets
you hear some conservatives say i hate
the tweets he's got to stop tweeting
then you
hear other ones like me who say i love
the tweets i get that the tweets can be
annoying
and sometimes they can be they can be a
little bit destructive
but the tweets are essential you've got
to keep badgering because it's the only
way
that you can break through that liberal
establishment that's the
you know ronald reagan famously said
there's only one guaranteed way that you
can have
peace and you can have it in the next
minute surrender
yeah if you surrender to the left then
you can it'll all be genial and nice oh
joel joe's a return to normalcy
i don't like the normalcy the normalcy
was very bad the normalcy
is leading our country off of a cliff
the normalcy that we're talking about
has led to a place where we've probably
haven't been this racially divided
in 50 years we've never been this
sexually divided because of the advent
of these new identity groups that have
cropped up we've never hated our country
more it's now controversial to listen to
the national anthem and stand up and
support your country it's now
controversial to recite the pledge of
allegiance or salute the flag
we've never hated our history more
tearing down statues of george
washington
thomas jefferson we've never been
stupider and this is the biggest problem
with this debate
is how stupid it was it was so dumb and
that's not just a
perennial complaint and every generation
feels that oh gosh things used to be
better
they actually were better when it comes
to the american mind and the american
public discourse
okay when you compare this debate
right which i think is a consequential
one i think 2020 is going to be
extremely consequential because you've
got so radically different visions for
the country
compare that to the lincoln douglas
debates which also were consequential
they also were about an essential
fundamental question in the country
slavery the question was so essential
that you had a
bloody civil war where almost 700 000
americans died over it
the lincoln douglas debates were
substantive the rhetoric from both sides
more so from lincoln but from both sides
the rhetoric the oratory was serious
it was contemplative it reflected a deep
mind
two deep minds actually with a deep
understanding of the issues
and last night was just yeah come on man
you're bae a racist man
you're shut up clown you man it was just
pathetic
mostly joe biden much less so trump
trump got his trumpy lines and he's a
reality tv star sure but joe biden was
the much
more pathetic one pitiful i won't even
say pathetic he didn't
he didn't evoke much much uh
compassionate feeling in me for him it
was it was sad
makes people sad for the country and if
you if you want to have that return to
normal saying just give it to joe
biden fine you're going to get more of
that more of that degradation
sometimes the only way out is through
dante famously
in his comedy where he's trying to get
up to heaven and and
behold the beatific vision he's got to
go all the way down through hell
sometimes the only way out
is through there are lots and lots of
lies not just in the debate but
that the typical lies coming from the
mainstream media it's going to involve a
lot more pestering
all of these threats and by the way
we've got
threats looking at the 2020 election in
november
a lot of it is going to be digital it's
going to be virtual
and you have got to protect your data
okay the way to do that is with
life lock i know sometimes you think no
one's coming after my data they're only
coming after the other guys
it's not true it's not true it's very
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft affect our lives
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet
you could miss certain identity threats
by just monitoring your credit
it's a good start it doesn't go far
enough good thing there's lifelock which
detects a wide range of identity threats
like for instance your social security
number for sale on the dark
web if they detect your information they
will send you
an alert okay we all do these things
maybe you use the same password for
every website
i think a lot of us a lot of us have
done that maybe
you are careless about how you send
information around
that can lead you you wouldn't even know
it that can lead to your private
information being
put for sale to very bad people no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but you can find out if your information
is on the dark web
do it right now get a free dark web scan
at lifelock.com
knowles pick the plan that's right for
you save up to twenty five percent
off your first year with promo code
knowles krw les that is a free scan
at lifelock.comwles 25
off with promo code knowles canon wles
the the trouble that we get to in these
debates
is the lies all of the lies that
the moderators quote unquote will lie on
behalf of the democrats
and they will contradict the republicans
and they will defend
the lies of the democrats there is one
clear one last night
that just shows you how rigged this game
is which we'll get to in one second but
if you liked our debate coverage last
night you should join daily wire now
as an insider all access member you get
20 off with
code debate so you can watch all of our
upcoming debate coverage live at
dailywire.com on apple tv
or on the roku app you get a ton of
stuff and you get
two leftist tears tumblers can't beat
that head on over to dailywire.com
become an all access member
20 off with code debate sign up today
we'll be right back with a lot more
give you an example of a clear lie there
was
an anonymous report confirmed by
confirmed quote by anonymous people
that said that trump called the troops
fallen soldiers idiots and losers and
suckers and that sort of thing
no evidence zero evidence that this ever
happened you have over 25 people
gone on the record even people who don't
like trump on the record saying now i
was there he never said that that's
complete bs
this was a story published by the
atlantic it doesn't matter because
they were clearly connected to the joe
biden campaign because joe biden
immediately makes ads
using that story within hours of the
story coming out so
joe biden launches that attack on trump
then trump points out he says wait joe
there's video of you calling the troops
stupid bastards
joe biden flat out denies it he made a
statement about the military he said i
said something about the military
he and his friends made it up and then
they went with it i never said it okay
the vice president
he said stupid
i love chris wallace stop it stop it
trump you're saying things that are true
and they're not nice about joe stop
please cut the feed cut his mic
it's so ridiculous but you heard the
important exchanges
joe biden called the troops stupid
bastards joe biden said i did not say
that
roll the tape one i married jill
and two i appointed johnson to the
academy i just want you to know that
it's clap for that you stupid basket
we have the tape he is talking to
a whole audience of military
says clap for that you stupid bastard
you called them stupid bastards
i did not how dare you so he lies
and then chris wallace stop please no oh
gosh people are gonna google it if you
mention it a couple more times and
that's it
that's it the only way you can break
through is if you if you hammer these
things
and you make it such an issue that even
if you get the negative attention for
yourself people take a look google it
themselves
those are the lies we're up against so
give you an example of another lie that
we're up against
so you remember the atlantic hit piece
that said
that uh trump called the military
suckers and losers no evidence of that
here's another one also from the
atlantic trump secretly mocks
his christian supporters former aides
say that in private the president has
spoken with citizen
cynicism and contempt about believers
you don't even really need to read this
it's like okay oh they've
they're quoting michael cohen the
criminal degenerate traitor
lawyer to donald trump coward
hack uh who's now in prison right or
maybe they let him out because he was
afraid of getting the wu flu or
something
okay blah blah i don't there's not i
don't even need to really read this
do you think that donald trump hates
christians ask yourself that do you
think donald trump
hates christians joe biden
in the biden obama administration that
administration sued
nuns took it all the way up through the
courts
because they wanted the nuns to pay for
abortion drugs
sued nuns
donald trump doesn't do that
donald trump supports religious liberty
supports
churches when the left
went over and burned down one of the
most famous
churches in the country st john's over
in washington dc right by the white
house
donald trump walked over there dispersed
the crowd of
rioters and held up the bible as a sign
of support and you know what happened
democrats attack trump for doing that
which side do you think supports
christianity which side do you think
holds christianity and contempt
how many churches have been burned down
graffitied up
attacked smashed by the left in the in
the last two months
countless which do you think this story
was i mean i what is the meat of this
story that trump has made some jokes
maybe i don't i guess i have no doubt
that trump has made jokes
about uh religious people i've made
plenty of jokes about religious people
many of them on this show
is that that's the issue no question is
who supports christianity trump or joe
biden joe biden who is denied communion
because he is in
grave scandal and mortal sin obviously
obviously trump is the supporter of
people of faith religious liberty
christianity in particular
this gets to that that issue of the
cynicism right
joe biden undermining his own attacks
because we've been told the last few
weeks
joe biden's a devout catholic sure he
doesn't believe the stuff the catholic
church believes
and sure he was denied communion rightly
so by a priest
but he's devout and that's so wonderful
but also amy barrett's a complete
nut job because she actually believes in
catholicism
well hold i thought it was good to
believe in because you said it was he's
a devout catholic and that's a good but
then you someone actually
and dianne feinstein is worried that the
dogma lives loudly within her and dick
durbin doesn't know what it means to
have orthodoxy in your religion
they're trying to have it both ways
which is what makes an article like that
complete
trash but that's what you're up against
so trump's got his work cut out for him
the one the one substantive point i want
to
tell republicans and president trump in
particular that i think is always a
misstep
trump made it last night is trump went
after joe biden on the 1994 crime bill
he went after joe biden for being too
tough on crime
which is a completely misguided attack
republicans are launching this i think
is a matter of racial pandering
and i actually find it racially very
uncomfortable because it conflates black
people with criminals like as a complete
overlap right
you're saying no look i'm really good
for black people look i'm letting them
all out of prison you say no
no i don't think innocent black people
want to identify themselves with a bunch
of criminals who who have done heinous
things
the 1994 crime bill is the only good
thing joe biden's ever done in his
political career
it makes me more likely to vote for him
if you mention the 94 crime bill
the first step act the jail spring act
that that trump passed
it actually makes me less likely to vote
for trump i'm obviously going to support
trump
regardless but it's my least favorite
thing probably that he's done in his
administration
he is it's the wrong line of attack it's
not going to work
it's uh it's it's undercutting their
other arguments on law order
give you an example give you an example
of how the left is just
by its own nature very weak on crime
there was a
a guy a murderer who just got executed
he finally got his
his punishment his just punishment which
is capital punishment
the u.s plans to execute a man for a
crime he committed at 19.
scientists say the research on brain
development makes that wrong
so first of all the scientists
say by the left's own premises
cannot have a conclusion in a moral
argument because what the leftist said
is that there is
science right physical science and that
you can't derive an ought from an is you
can't derive
moral conclusions from the physical
world that's that's the basis of this
whole
physical science that we're talking
about but what they're what are they
trying to do they're trying to drive
a moral conclusion from the physical
world
right but they're saying those things
are supposed to be totally separate
scientists and philosophers supposed to
be totally separate
but they don't separate them when it
works for them so they'll say yes
science says you gotta you gotta lock
yourself in your home for the next 10
years
because science science says that no
nothing
nothing about science as they understand
it would suggest that
it gets more complicated because one
actually
probably can derive an ought from it
from an is probably actually can derive
moral conclusions from the physical
world but that that
argument is for another day and that's
certainly not what the what the left is
trying to do they're actually trying to
invert that traditional understanding of
things
the man committed a crime at 19 and now
he's got to pay for first of all he
should have been executed at 19 right it
should he shouldn't have been
languishing on on death row for the past
21 years
they should have just executed him for
his crime but then they're trying to
racially demagogue it because apparently
apparently this guy is black
he doesn't look black to me but i guess
he's black so a number of the
the uh articles about this in the tweets
about this have said the us is going to
execute a black man
and the premise of blm is that any black
man who's in prison is there unjustly
because we have a
new kind of slavery and i don't know
they were all set up or something
let me tell you this guy's crime
christopher v alva
christopher villalva bummed a ride from
two youth ministers a
young couple a man and his wife he
robbed them
he kidnapped them and he stuffed them in
the trunk
he then drove around for hours and tried
to
pawn the wife's wedding ring apparently
unsuccessfully
he then opened up the trunk and while
they were pleading for their lives the
wife was reading him
the bible to convert him
he shot them both in the head but the
wife didn't die right away
so he set their bodies on fire
and then they died
this is by the way this man would end up
in the in dante's sort of understanding
of
cosmic justice this guy would end up in
the very
pit the very lowest level of hell he
committed the worst
sin which is fraud and betraying
specifically
betraying your benefactors he asked
these guys for a ride
out of the kindness of their heart they
gave it to him he
kidnapped them robbed them tied them up
and burned this woman alive
that guy should be killed
by the state it is totally just
capital punishment very just thing it
perverts our system when there is no
type of justice at that degree
when the president comes out i
understand there's a very big difference
between say a drug crime
and a crime such as christopher vyalva
committed though i will point out
with some of these drug trafficking
rings there is a lot of blood involved
there's a lot of death involved in those
too
but i get it they're different when
republicans come out and attack
democrats for being too tough on crime
you know they've lost the threat because
we do not have a problem in this country
being too tough on crime
we are way way way too weak on crime
even conservatives
many conservatives oppose capital
punishment many conservatives even
oppose tough punishment
because it's not rehabilitative maybe
it's not
it's not deterrent they say now it often
is determined the reason that these
tough punishments are not deterred is
because they go on so long that they
don't
they don't actually seem like a
punishment if this guy had been killed
at 20
as he damn well should have been i think
you'd see a
much greater deterrent effect of capital
punishment they're not rehabilitative i
i bet capital punishment has at least a
chance of being rehabilitative on this
man's soul
but there is a primary purpose of
our justice system which is justice
justice
it's not just a therapy session folks
it's justice
punitive punitive punishment i know that
that sounds a little bit redundant
retributive justice that's
what we're talking about getting
retribution because
justice demands it there's a role for
mercy too
that's the pardon power but there is a
there's a place for justice as well
we've completely lost that
you know what's so funny too we're also
being we're being very very cruel to the
the prisoners in the process
i'll give you an example in california
governor gavin newsom has now decided
that he's going to send
transgender inmates that is men
who pretend to be women to be housed
with the women prisoners
with the women and what could go wrong
what could go wrong get a bunch of
hardened
criminals people who are by definition
criminals who do bad things to people
put a bunch of these bad dudes in with
the women what could possibly go wrong
this is
horrifically cruel to the female inmates
and by the way i'm calling for tough
justice on criminals but i'm not calling
for cruelty
i think it's very wrong to i think it's
extraordinarily wrong to be cruel
i totally oppose cruel and unusual
punishment
this is cruel and unusual punishment
putting a bunch of men
in with the women what could possibly go
wrong
but it's because we've lost this threat
of calling out
objective moral reality it actually gets
to the science question
you see there was there was a time when
we could understand
that the physical world has a purpose my
body has a purpose
that this this life that we have has an
end
okay the this cup has a purpose the cup
is to
give me coffee
that there are other things the cup
could be used for and there's some
things that the cup should not be
used for the cup is not a telephone i
can't use the cup to be a telephone it
is it is
not going to fulfill its tea loss it's
not going to fulfill its purpose by
doing that but the cup
is here for giving me that delicious
coffee
then you had the kind of quote-unquote
scientific revolution where we say no no
you can't derive any of these kind of
philosophical or metaphysical
conclusions from physical objects but
now we've reverted back to the old thing
it's just on the left right it's the
left saying yeah the scientists the lab
coat guys
who have no understanding of ethics or
philosophy those guys are now going to
tell us
how to run our moral lives based on
nothing based on their
their wild whims
what we have to do is return to a world
in which
we have a clear understanding of the
moral order and where we have the
courage to admit it
say some things are better than other
things there is such a thing as justice
there is such a thing as good there is
such a thing as courage there is such a
thing as wrong
men should not be with the women inmates
that's wrong
men who pretend to be women we should
have compassion for
sure but we shouldn't indulge that
fantasy because it's not true
it's wrong it is actually wrong to do
that
wrong to pretend to do that and wrong to
indulge that delusion
there's a kindergarten teacher in france
kindergarten teacher just got fired
from teaching kindergarten he's he's
still teaching first graders and second
graders and third graders he just got
fired from kindergarten why
sylvan helene is his name he's 35 he's
the most tattooed man in
in france his body face and tongue are
covered in tattoos and he just had the
whites of his eyeballs
surgically dyed black to look like a
demon he looks like a demon
and he was scaring the kindergarteners
so
finally he was moved not out of the not
out of the school
not away from children not into a
psychiatric hospital where he belongs
he was moved to first grade and
hopefully those kids and their parents
won't complain and have nightmares
there was a time in this civilization
where you could look at that and say you
know
it's it is wrong to
dye your whole skin and dye your
eyeballs black and try to look like a
demon
that's wrong that's evidence that
something's going wrong in your head and
we're going to give you treatment for
that
we're going to explain to you why that's
wrong but now we're so afraid to make
any
moral moral claim and and they're even
conservatives quote unquote they're
really libertarians
who say well you know look if we say
it's wrong to uh dye your eyeballs black
and and cover your whole body and
tattoos to look like a demon
then they're gonna tell us it's wrong to
go to church and it's like who can
really know which one's wrong you know
so we just gotta throw our hands up and
anything goes
no i'll tell you what how about we just
say the good things are the good things
and the bad things are the bad things
we've done that throughout the entirety
of our civilization except for the past
i don't know five minutes
in earnest since the 1960s how about we
just do that
that is possible we have the ability to
do that
we just might not have the courage
that all of that is to say that is a
system
that conservatives are up against right
now okay that kind of
insanity that kind of unreason and so
it is no surprise that when we have our
national debates
it's just a bunch of screaming all night
long it's just a bunch of petty insults
there's no reason because we've lost
confidence even in the ability to reason
about our politics to reason about how
we ought to all live together
we've lost a conception of what the good
even
is what we all should be doing and so
we're all just stuck
in cacophony and a bunch of babble all
right that's enough babble for today
i'll see you tomorrow i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen
you